i was awesome you know  as a professional you gotta always stay  ready and i knew that last series was  small ball  and uh coach had already told us that  it's gonna be a tough place to get  minutes because of how houston plays  so you know instead of you know getting  upset and  you know just howling you know just  decided to just go go get ready for this  this series against where we played next  and happened to be good  so i'm just very thankful that i got an  opportunity to get out there and play  and  i wanted to give my teammates everything  i got and  just pushed the limit what was the key  for you guys  dwight howard after the lakers game one  victory you liked the hoodie  no the hoodie was trash  i mean it was like cut a little too high  maybe  like wearing a hoodie in the middle of  this dwight come on  when